c'est incontestablement la star de la
chanson dont on entend le plus parler en
ce moment
à seulement 25 ans aia nakamura s'est
immédiatement installé sur la première
marche du podium des artistes les plus
populaires du moment était lente et son
premier album en 2010 est elle se fit
remarquer avec journal a team honda
retenant à des comportements mais c'est
son deuxième opus nakamura qui fait
d'elle une star avec des tubes comme
boucly copines ou encore djadja aya
inonde les radios et les réseaux sociaux
un album qu'elle a écoulé à un million
d'exemplaires et il ne s'agit pas d'un
succès exclusivement francophone
la star a écoulé plus de la moitié de
ses albums à l'étranger en 2020 elles
mêmes l'artiste française la plus
écoutée sur la plateforme petit fail
avec pas moins de 13 millions
d'auditeurs par mois
le 13 novembre dernier la nouvelle reine
de la pop française vient de sortir son
troisième album comment on fait
la planète toute entière a cédé aux
charmes des mélodies entraînantes de
l'artiste comme les filles de madonna
ou comme le prouvent ses affiches
géantes sur times square en plein coeur
de manhattan
une artiste dont tout le monde parle et
qui pourtant n'est pas forcément la plus
présente sur les plateaux comme on a pu
le constater la semaine dernière alors
qu'elle devait être présente sur le
plateau le quotidien elle a annulé sa
venue au dernier moment soit disant
parce qu'elle aurait eu la flemme
une information que la jeune femme
dément ni flamme ni plan j'avais prévenu
depuis 13h pourtant les contretemps ça
arrive une annulation qui serait en
réalité dû à une mésentente avec
l'équipe
en effet la production de l'émission lui
aurait imposé des danseuses avec
lesquels la chanteuse était en conflit
des ventes record des concerts plein à
craquer et une renommée internationale
alors selon maya nakamura était la plus
grande star française du moment on pose
la question chez vous également et oui
oui oui
alors moi je dois dire je suis fan j'ai
toujours dit dans cette émission et je
trouve qu'elle a tout de la star ah
ouais quand même
la diva ouais la diva est l'atout c'est
formidable ce qu'elle fait elle a un
vrai langage un peu nous vaut aussi pour
les jeunes
l'un fait landers et musique elle est
formidable elle est d'une très grande
beauté mais j'adore quand il y en a qu à
moi sur la tête de ma mère je sais ce
que je disais tout à l'heure
cheese et où l'équipe cheese et nous on
essaie d'appeler daqian rihanna n'a
qu'un mois et demi elle te répondront
jamais ses mimes norme ce cas oui
j'appelle la mini du logement il me
répond ah yan a qu'à moi je suis sûr que
je l'appelle je l'aï appelé je vous dis
aime répondra pas alors on va aller les
bd vous êtes fan aussi un oui dans les
mosquées ce qui me plaît c'est justement
que ce côté indomptables c'est à dire
une star ce qu'on veut c'est qu'elle
fasse que ce qu'elle veut c'est qu'elle
nous surprennent et conférence est voilà
irrévérencieuse et c'est le club aille à
west savaria ça va vers ses trois
passions en direct je suis dans
l'émission je croyais pas que j'allais
me rappelle trop lourd
et c'est comment je te kiffe tu peux
même pas savoir mais sans lui même est
un génie je vais dire alors je dis la
vérité
tout ce que c'était franchement on il
est ici que tu es la plus grande pour
moi tu es la plus grande artiste
française du moment et je vais te dire
tu sais ce que tu as je te jure et je le
pense vraiment tu es une star est une
star est une star voilà non mais je te
le jure
et tu sais pourquoi tu peux faire ce que
tu fais c'est parce que quand on a du
talent on peut faire ce qu'on veut en
fait c'est vrai tu sais quoi tu attends
pas à toi après les émissions après tu
t'en vas les steaks attendait son mégot
les labels sont pas les steaks j'ai vu
alors c'est pas parce que t'as pas été
jusqu'au 10 ans plus dur 1.8 aurait été
jusqu'au tina jours et qu'il faut aussi
mais l'histoire elle est simple ils ont
mis des danseurs qu'elle qui fait pas je
comprends moi c'est comme si demain je
vais un ton à tennessee mettre des gens
que je kiffe pas j'y vais pas marion
mais c'est énorme
voilà je voulais te dire je suis fan de
toi mais tu qui retournera voilà attire
tournoi non juste tu sais que voilà
pourquoi pas mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui je trouve que tu es
vraiment la plus grande star du moment
par une écoute parce qu'ils veulent
parler de toi oui guillaume gens dont on
parle de star française mais en fait
c'est une star internationale
il faut savoir qu'un artiste qui
cartonne en france saf est allé 50
millions de vues sur youtube djadja ces
700 millions de vues serait ce qu'un
milliard de vues elle a chanté avec
malouda qui est le plus gros artistes
latinos au monde
elle a un featuring avec ce tandis qu'un
gros rappeur anglais c'est une star
internationale et où vous alliez dans le
monde vous entend déjà déjà en asie en
amérique et c'est assez vrai et à ce
jour c'est la belle 16e artistes les
plus écoutées au monde devant lady gaga
et cardy est devenue comme une fois tu
vois tout ça très bien un truc sur toi
ya c'est que n'a pas du tout pris la
grosse tête moi je t'ai connu taëf et
des lives chez moi il ya très longtemps
et j'étais restée la même tout est lié
et aujourd'hui c'est juste justement
c'est parce qu'elle n'a pas changé
quelle est elle est restée communauté
avant donc voilà si elle a des trucs
avec ses ailes et elle est comme ça elle
n'a pas changé
si les gens qui ont changé en fait
autour d'elle ce qu'on veut aux six mois
- pardon
mais elle fait aussi des caprices et
tant mieux c'est pas grave parce qu'on
aime par exemple de mariah carey c'est
qu'on puisse raconter des histoires
mêmes fantasmes et autour d'eux
peut-être qu'elle fait comme si ce n'est
de café comme ça c'est ça qu'on a qu'on
n'a plus aujourd'hui de ce jour d'hui
des gens qui font un peu fantasmé dont
on raconte des légendes autour d'eux il
ya des légendes sur toi il ya le fait d'
énorme bisou et tu sais que je t'aime
sort et voilà embraer et y est le nouvel
album d'aia estivale car on ne sait quoi
toi faisons plutôt des mois tu m'as pas
besoin de faire de promo c'est vrai que
ces deux qu'elle a pas besoin
t'as pas besoin c'est un énorme carton
et tu le mérites je t'embrasse très fort
un garçon je t'embrasse très fort merci
d'avoir avec lui